las sociedades de américa latina están
cambiando en perú además de las
elecciones presidenciales el congreso
tendrá una nueva formación y entre sus
nuevos diputados podría estar angela
billón madre de cinco hijos que durante
35 años vivió en situación de
prostitución y lidera el movimiento de
trabajadoras sexuales de perú porque las
también votamos y decidimos dejar
de ser utilizadas para nosotras también
ser autoridad pero autoridad en el buen
sentido la palabra para poder cambiar
nuestra realidad una diversidad que
llega a las personas trans gael a carl y
busca sus 28 años ser la primera
congresista trans de perú un camino
lleno de obstáculos y mucho compromiso y
sufrí en carne propia las y las
consecuencias de la desigualdad de la
discriminación de la violencia de la
corrupción del extractivismo no por eso
y hago política a estas candidaturas
comprometidas se les suman otras más
folclóricas como milagros suárez que
disfrazada de un personaje de dibujos
animados japonés y portando un peluche
pikachu hace campaña ya creemos que por
medio del anime del manga de cosplay y
también quizás el gaming se introduzca
en concepto de peruanidad se introduzcan
historias en base al imperio incaico un
mosaico diverso donde nos falta el
cristo cholo julio mario valencia es
famoso por vestirse de jesucristo y
recorrer las calles de lima cargando una
cruz en esta particularidad de esta
candidatura voy a levantar mi bandera de
la paz voy a levantar mi bandera del
perdón y voy a levantar mi bandera de la
reconsideración para que todos los
peruanos nos perdonemos unas elecciones
que a través de la diversidad muestran
que una nueva sociedad está llegando a
américa latina'